in this video we'll talk about renin
Angiotensin aldosterone system which is
a hormonal system that regulates blood
volume and blood pressure this
particular system can regulate blood
pressure fluid and electrolyte balance
and systemic vascular resistance it all
begins when there is a drop in the
glomerular blood pressure
the juxtaglomerular cells secrete a
particular protein known as weaning
renine can convert liver derived
angiotensinogen
into
Angiotensin one further Angiotensin 1
gets converted to another active form
known as Angiotensin II and this is with
the help of the lung derived Angiotensin
converting enzyme
now the key player here is the
Angiotensin II Angiotensin 2 can act on
the
adrenal gland and it can also act on the
blood vessels
so in the adrenal so at the adrenal
gland aldosterone is secreted
aldosterone can lead to sodium and water
retention and reabsorption in the kidney
and Angiotensin II can directly act on
the blood vessels on the capillary
endothelial cells which lead to
vasoconstriction
all these things increases the blood
pressure and try to bring back the
pressure homeostasis
aldosterone increases sodium in the
bloodstream that's why water is also
retained and there is a overall increase
in the blood volume which can restore
the decreased pressure
now Angiotensin to further act on the
pituitary gland which lead to the
secretion of anti-diuretic hormone
antidiuretic hormone further helps in
water reabsorption and It ultimately
retains water and increases the blood
volume so all this system is dedicated
to bring back the pressure into a
homeostatic level so it's a safeguard
mechanism in our body
now let me tell you there are several
problems with this system if this system
is hyperactive there would be an
increase in the blood pressure
so that is why there are many
medications which can Target molecules
in this pathway
first of all the class of inhibitor
known as s Inhibitors inhibit the
Angiotensin converting enzyme that would
prevent the production of Angiotensin II
automatically the vasoconstrictive
activity and the sodium and water
retention activity would be decreased
also there are other Inhibitors which
inhibits the Angiotensin binding to the
Angiotensin receptor so these receptor
Inhibitors further decrease the blood
pressure so many of the medications that
are generally prescribed to patients to
control blood pressure uses or Targets
this particular pathway and from a
pharmacological point of view this
pathway is super important for
regulating the blood pressure
so overall the goal of rash system is to
regulate blood pressure homeostasis
so now we understand that running
Angiotensin aldosterone system is a
tightly regulated system and it needs to
be fine-tuned too much is bad too little
is also bad
so how does this fine tuning Works
Angiotensin 2 has a short half-life less
than a minute that means Angiotensin 2
which is very potent gets converted to
less potent forms such as Angiotensin 3
or Angiotensin IV
so this is how a pressure homeostasis is
maintained
so I hope this overall was useful if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can follow me on Facebook
or Instagram to get more notes you can
support our channel in super thanks see
you in next video